last week we were doing algebra and the
most recent thing you learnt was
something to do with like terms now
before we get to what that D was I need
somebody help me what are like terms
yeah maybe you're just what else when I
step in
what did Jordan tell me what I like - I
can't fantastic now terms of the like
each other let me give you an example
cuz a like is kind of a vague word so
for example I think these terms are like
each other they both have threes I then
like terms okay so there's a couple of
things that I notice about these correct
they are not like terms the first thing
you've noticed is there's like this
multiplication happening in here isn't
it it's kind of kind of happening on the
sly this is really shorthand for three
plus three times egg isn't it okay so
there's not just that third the big
thing that I'm looking for that makes
these unlike is that you can see this
algebra hanging out here is a pronumeral
a variable and unknown talked about
these times before and over here they
just have a number right so these guys
are in fact on like but you finally
change this just a little bit
it's chucking in something like this
okay now I have like terms right which
terms are the like terms
yeah up the back Daniel fantastic the
three and the five okay they are alike
because they're both just numbers
no algebra attached right so I can't
and this is what you did very very
recently with these like terms I can
collect them
so collecting light turns was the most
recent skill that you were developing
okay so this should be equal to 8 plus 3
okay let's change one more thing that's
add another like term onto there suppose
I said let's do must be really
interesting
let's check this on the end of
everything ok now again another like
term but because it's got algebra and
it's got the same per normal as I have
over here these guys have like terms now
right makes it 3 a + -7 a really
important to capture there's a minus
sign there right and the - kind of hangs
along like a like a bad smell to the 7 a
okay so 3 a and a minus 7 a so when I
put them together when I collect them
what do I get
fantastic well I'm ready so I'm going to
paste minus 4 and that's that's how I
would use collecting like tips okay now
one last thing to notice when we put
together this 3 a.m. this -7 a the A's
didn't disappear it didn't become like
minus 4 as if oh I've got a I'm gonna
take away a right there's multiplication
hiding in there right so what this is
really short for is a plus a plus a and
this is short for what's it shuffle hmm
yep okay
class but except except it's up it's a
minus sign isn't it right so B minus a
minus a 7 one more time there we go
seven times
okay that was collecting like terms but
now when you step it up a little bit and
you have to be careful because some
parts of this are similar and some parts
are quite different multiplying and
dividing terms is what we're gonna do
and even though you can see on your
textbook these are broken up into two
separate exercises they're really the
same idea because division is just
multiplying in the verse okay so let's
have a go at these right let's pick up
why at question
you're gonna go straight into from here
we'll do it together first we'll do a
few of these okay
so pleased with me it's not going to
take a huge amount of time right the
question with me five times 3y okay now
when you are multiplying these things
together in some senses it doesn't
matter anymore whether they're like four
unlike because we're multiplying or
dividing to go together all right so
here I can think about these numbers
right this is really short for well tell
me against what's 3y and abbreviation on
yeah fantastic
5 times 3 times y like you just told me
okay so now you can see I can multiply
these in any order I like some others
well put together these two numbers cuz
I mean I'm good at we do say 5 times 3
is 15 X so I can do 15 times y but I
could just say Y on some bump I've
multiplied together everything sort of
jammed together in one piece let's skip
over to okay so I've got 2 X together
how we
you always have to take something value
when you learn something Toki's driver's
license okay
I know you had to come back did you do
all right we're worried sorry 2x 2x you
remember we did a little bit of a note
on how you shouldn't write your ex's
like x just do whatever you can to not
confuse them with each other
2x x 8y okay he doesn't need now again
this time without writing it just doing
it in my head I'm gonna remember but
this is 2 times x times 8 times y okay
this is one long dinner there's a word
that starts really P that's the result
when you're multiply things together you
remember it's called yeah a product
fantastic this is just one long product
this times this times this times this
etc okay so if it's 2 times x times 8
times y I'm gonna put the two NBA
together at the front right and then
I've got the X and the y hanging out at
the end because I usually put my prayer
nails at the end it off medical orderly
nice so now you can tell me once it's
gonna be equal to 16 X Y now the X of
the why'd it go away
right then it disappeared I don't know
what the numbers are equal to so I just
have to leave them there they're still
unknowns
ok let's go for a trickier one let's go
for let's go for I because that's a bit
of a it's a bit of a pain
yeah me too
so kgs don't Morgan thank you would be
totally a careful son but it's not
alright now this one is a bit trickier
and you have to be very careful with
them in fact to help you if you have
another color it's not necessary but we
should be helpful at least I find it is
ok I've got three Pro numeral to you
H J and K in kind of this reader
arrangement right so what I want to do
is I want to work out how many H's do I
have and how many days and how many Kate
okay now this time like I did before I'm
gonna write it out in longhand to make
an obvious point okay so what's this
thing really equal to its H times J
times K times but you get the idea
let's write out the whole thing okay and
the reason why this is so helpful is
because this will help us get the answer
right how many H is I'm that's the first
letter alphabetically how many H done
I see 2 1 2 so with my other color I'll
do something like underline them now
I've got 2 HS ah but I'm not adding the
memo right I'm multiplying them thanks
sir that's exactly right
so really H times H is H squared very
good it feels like it should be all I
got 2 inches to H but you get 2 H if you
were adding them all right I'll just
write that up in h plus h is 2h right
but H times H is H squared right it's a
really subtle looking difference but
when you write out all the
multiplication signs you can see oh it's
H times H ok so that's the first thing
I'm gonna write H squared okay I'm not
done yet
how many J's under that's the next thing
medically there are three I'll do this
I'll make it a little bit differently so
confuse them okay so circle is
J and J right this example is simple
enough you can a client you can kind of
do it in your head but we'll get to
examples where it's like wanna learn you
need to do everything you can to help
yourself make sure you don't miss any
turns okay sir in a three J's J times J
times J Triple J okay so what should I
write it's J cute very good right it
feels like on three J's I should write
three J but you're not adding them
you're multiplying them so Jade cute
last one you probably get the point now
how many keys are there is two K there
and you came and you can use like a
dotted lines indicate it so case way
thanks baby done there you go
see we put it all together there are no
actual numbers that we know what they
are there's no fifteen or sixteen
hanging out the front that's all we've
got
question okay so you put put x here in
time see if you liked what generally
when we put the letters together to save
some space we don't write the
multiplications okay we do we do that
with pronumerals
we don't do with numbers though because
if I wrote five times three as five
three with that that means something
else doesn't it so you can't just jam
numbers together but you can jam pretty
rows together because we're not
confusing that with oh yeah you doing
that that number HJ I love that that's
my favorite number now we know that that
means H times Jack